et c'est dans cette ambiance détestable
que le danois michael rasmussen est
arrivé en tête en haut du col de
l'aubisque un maillot jaune sifflé à
plusieurs reprises si le public est
toujours aussi nombreux ils manifestent
de plus en plus aux hostilités
reportage je les avais des taux et
jean-marc notebook conçu au départ
sifflé à l'arrivée aujourd'hui michael
rasmussen a essuyé des signes flagrants
de désamour mais il a encore gagné en
écrasant la concurrence dans la
difficile montée de l'aubisque
dans ce col qui a fait la légende de la
course la passion pour le tour c'est à
l'achat classé mais l affaire vinokourov
en a déçu plus d'un
ici personne n'est dupe sommet coeur que
vinokourov a volé la victoire d'étape à
quelqu'un qui aurait été plus propre
contador est ce qui paraît il est monté
à 40 cents à excuser les attaques dans
la côté face c'est impossible on fait
des courses mais bon c'est vrai que ça
bouge quand on les voit monter servent à
éponger l'excès les professionnels en
plein effort dans la montée finale
rasmussen multiplie les gestes
d'énervement les motos placé devant lui
l' empêche d'attaquer son dauphin au
classement alberto contador tente de le
distancer
en vain le jeune espagnol jouit ici
d'une popularité sans faille
il est doublé contador rasmussen je sais
pas trop mais ils ont été contrôlés tous
les deux rassoul scène et contador et on
n'a rien trouvé un kilomètre du sommet à
rasmussen lâche ses rivaux il signe sa
deuxième victoire d'étape dans ce tour
le maillot jaune aimerait que ses
victoires soient reconnus à leur juste
valeur par ses détracteurs
peut-être qu'avec cette victoire les
gens vont enfin changer d'avis
moi j'ai consolider mon maillot et puis
j'ai trois minutes d'avancé maintenant
sur contador ça devrait suffire
imbattable dans les pyrénées le danois a
quasiment course gagnée mais il aura
bien du mal à éliminer son principal
adversaire le soupçon